stick around for the rest of this video
we have a lot to show you after these
messages this video is sponsored by War
Planet online a massive multiplayer
online strategy game available on mobile
platforms as well as PC and mac and
warplanet online you can launch a global
Warfare assault strategy using real-time
strategy to command and Conquer adapt
your tactics recruit commanders and
order your army to battle in combat
against both players online and AI
troops war is always evolving you can
also build your own custom base to
survive your enemies assault and
stockpile troops tanks and helicopters
and Conquer key cities like New York
Paris Moscow and Tokyo play with players
from around the world who can either
become members of your alliance and help
you conquer Nations or become your next
targets my favorite thing about the game
is just how massive these battles can
get making this truly feel like a global
conflict there's so much action to keep
track of all at once and a classic
cinematic Action Hero is joining The
Fray from First Blood one of my favorite
classic action films John Rambo is
joining wpo on a special mission to
guide the players through the secrets of
warfare lead the way through the first
Blood chain event operation and help the
players become a one-man Army for a
limited time ramble will create a truly
captivating and explosive experience for
all players and it gets even better as
the first 40 players who download the
game now and reach level 10 before
November 10th will win a 100 Amazon
e-gift card expect the winners to be
announced on November 25th and contacted
in-game additionally there has never
been a better time to download the game
just click on my link in the description
or scan the QR code in the corner and
you'll get 4 000 Army units T1 and 4 000
medals for an even bigger Head Start in
the game what's more you can benefit
from the great Rambo event see you there
now back to the video
[Music]
are you afraid I'm going to turn into
some kind of criminal quit worrying
about me okay something's different I'll
figure it out stop lecturing me please I
don't mean to lecture and I don't need
to preach and I know I'm not your father
then stop pretending to be oh hey we're
here
[Music]
foreign
I love going to a cabin in the woods to
spend time with my totally platonic male
friends
it'd be nice to have a vacation after
all that questionably Canon alien and
Predator business just me my buddies and
my own two hands
I've been brought my socially anxious
sister for some reason
[Music]
the James and Maddie say they can make
it they said they were having car
trouble I don't know they were saying
something
foreign
that was almost as bad as the automatic
doors at s mark
those things close with some Force
hey check it out this book looks like
somebody melted SpongeBob in the
microwave
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
who threw this
I don't know I bet it looked really sick
though
[Music]
how does one describe Evil Dead to
someone that's never seen it uh alright
Imagine The Exorcist scary
demon-possessed girl beating up her mom
and levitating furniture and shouting
foul language now imagine that instead
of a nervous priest reciting Bible
passages to defeat the evil presence
before him it's just a really handsome
dumb guy slashing the demon to pieces
with a chainsaw and then saying a Snappy
action movie one-liner that sounds like
easily the coolest thing ever obviously
and I'm a huge fan of the franchise from
four movies to a TV show and hundreds of
Comics Evil Dead is the ongoing
Adventures of Ash Williams a bumbling
hard-headed grocery store employee who
finds himself wrapped up in a battle of
Good vs Evil in the fate of the world
even though he just wants to go home
it's sort of like turning the chosen one
narrative on its head by asking what if
the chosen one was kind of a dick a
lovable one but still just
an amazing train wreck of a man and with
such a unique and well-loved character
with such a spectacularly original way
of facing off against the forces of evil
fans of the series have always wanted to
know what it was like to simulate being
in Ash's blood-soaked shoes for a day
and taking a chainsaw hand to a horde of
dead eyes themselves as such there have
been four-ish attempts in the last 25
years to create an Evil Dead video game
give or take a few weird side Ventures
that have varying levels of
entertainment value now that we're
locked away in a spooky cabin in the
woods with nothing to do but test them
out let's dig into what makes a good
Evil Dead game and how close any of
these came to bringing the king to
consoles much like the movie franchise
they're based on Evil Dead video games
came from humble beginnings starting
with the Evil Dead for the Commodore 64.
this adaptation of the first movie has
you take control of Ash inside a crude
Recreation of the cabin from a top-down
perspective as you fight off
mutants
mutants all right to be fair they never
actually said the word deadite in the
first movie in fact that word isn't
dropped until the very end of Evil Dead
2.
[Music]
it probably would have gone with like
the possessed or zombies or demons or
anything before mutants
gameplay here is pretty simple your goal
is to rack up enough points to spawn the
Book of the Dead and throw it into the
fireplace you can pick up weapons
throughout the cabin to dismember the
evil mutants they're lopped off body
parts can still actually chase you
around that's pretty cool for the time
there are some defensive strategies you
can take namely closing off the windows
in the front door to prevent the evil
force from making its way into the cabin
the gameplay mechanic I can only imagine
was a massive pain in the ass is how
this game's health system works mind you
I've never played this myself but from
looking at it literally everything you
do consumes from your energy counter
even something as simple as walking
around imagine being just a few points
away from beating the game only to die
by
taking a step shout out to Bruce
Campbell giving the player a tutorial
way back in 1984 though even if it isn't
a very indirect manner I can almost hear
his snark in this pixelated text in case
you haven't realized you're looking at
me from above
it's always cool coming back to these
really early games and seeing how they
convey story and plot points and ideas
from the movie in a very interpretive
and basic way because they had such
limited gameplay mechanics and Graphics
to work with back then
you gotta love how all three of these
games triumphantly announce Bruce
Campbell doing the voice on the back
covers they had their priorities
straight
first up is Evil Dead Hail to the King a
modest resident evil clone that was
released in 2000. this game serves as a
potential Evil Dead 4 where its plot
centers on Ash and his new girlfriend
Jenny returning to the cabin for some
emotional closure having spent the last
few years trying to recover from the
events of the films Upon returning Ash's
old severed hand reactivates the
recording that summons demons and the
nightmare begins again right where it
started I really love the design of the
backgrounds in this game and the fixed
camera look it's cool seeing the cabin
from the first two movies lovingly
rendered in the game with the same
layout so many memories here in all
these rooms some from yet to be released
sequels years later even Ash killed his
dad in this bathroom however this game's
biggest drawback is its combat against
the Demonic Undead third person fixed
camera angles a la Resident Evil and
Silent Hill don't really translate to
satisfying melee combat it's really
difficult to get yourself positioned
right to hack and slash a deadites
there's not really an auto aim when you
shoot at them with guns leading some
very clumsy enemy encounter others it's
not helped by the fact that the enemies
respawn infinitely in pretty much every
area of the game you knock them down and
they get right back up you'll be dead by
dawn for sure if you don't book it the
[ __ ] out of here an important mechanic
the game refuses to teach the player is
how to execute enemies and executing
deadites is huge if you don't know how
to do this the game is practically
unplayable I discovered this mechanic
completely by accident simply hacking
and slashing away with your chainsaw or
dumping ammo into every data you come
across would be a waste of resources
because these guys seem to eat lead for
breakfast I'm surprised the game doesn't
make a showpiece of these executions in
the back of the box or something because
even with this primitive PS1 animations
they look pretty cool there are unique
animations for each weapon and they're
made infinitely more badass when you
punctuate them with Ash's dedicated
one-liner button
come get some
much like most horror games from this
era the start of this game is the
hardest part when you don't know where
to go or what you're doing you're liable
to get your ass kicked a few times until
you start finding key items and figuring
out where to go and by figuring it out I
mean looking it up online because the
game's not very good at allowing you to
draw your own conclusions about what
goes where like this stupid hedge maze
Woods full of skeletons the biggest
offender is this God forsaken hedge maze
early on in the game every time I enter
this area I get turned around and end up
up my own ass I guess that's the point
of a maze but man if it isn't
frustrating as hell the way pre-rendered
backgrounds are drawn in this area make
it hard to tell what's a wall and what's
a passageway you can walk down there's a
map you can pull up at any time but it
doesn't lay out areas in a grid like
format like it would in Resident Evil
it's a hand-drawn map that gives you a
general idea of where the different
sections of the forest are in relation
to one another so it's not much help
here not not to mention that you have
these annoying boneheads chasing you
around all the time I dwell on this one
area of the game because I think it
makes for a really bad early impression
of it I have a strong feeling that this
is just about where most players reach
their break point and decide to call it
quits yep good God I hate this maze I
hate the skeletons I am so done also
this game doesn't tell you very clearly
that the item box is also the save point
so
spent several hours looking for a save
point not realizing I was walking by
several of them which is a shame because
once you get past this hurdle the rest
of the game is Smooth Sailing by
comparison you get to explore more of
the woods where you'll find the
campground and unstable mind and a
cemetery as you collect pages of the
Necronomicon after being advised by the
local priest we Face Off against some
varied bosses they're not challenging by
any means but some of them require you
to solve a simple puzzle in order to do
damage which goes a long way one of them
being a possessed Annie Nobby wielding
the kandarian dagger I wonder how she
managed to pull that out of her back did
she have help anyway it turns out that
the priest was actually evil Ash in
Disguise who was swindling our strong
jawed hero into Gathering the pages for
him he kidnaps Jenny and jumps through a
portal with Ash hot on his Trail if
re-experiencing the horrors of the cabin
wasn't enough we get to visit Medieval
Times once again this area is a lot
easier to navigate because it's nowhere
near as extensive as the woods actually
the game starts to feel a lot more
Linear by this point it almost feels
like the devs were in a rush to wrap
things up like the first task here is to
lower this bridge to do so you'll have
to gather pieces of a crank again very
Resident Evil rather than exploring the
environment to track down these pieces
you simply hang by the bridge where
skeletons will infinitely spawn and
periodically drop the pieces that you
need this is such a bizarre choice that
goes completely against what you've come
to expect from this game by this point
since when do regular enemies drop key
items eventually you catch up to evil
Ash who intends to sacrifice Jenny to
the dark ones Ash gets an upgrade man a
buzz saw this thing looks dumb give me
the chainsaw back the final boss fight
against evil Ash has two phases one
being a straightforward brawl in his
humanoid form and in the second phase he
transforms into a giant scorpion-like
Jedi the fight is really easy all you
have to do is hit these pillars which
cause the monster to get stunned
allowing you to do some damage using the
pages of the Necronomicon Ash opens a
portal that sucks the monster up with
Jenny safe it's time to hit the dusty
trail and open up another portal back
home in classic Evil Dead fashion the
pair end up in a messed up alternate
future while an economicon has been
published into a best-selling book
giving the masses easy access to evil
forces Ash
what the
weather
no
no
an evil dead game in the style of
Resident Evil is an idea that sounds
awesome on paper and I do believe
there's a good way to execute that
premise some of the shots from the movie
remind me of the fixed camera angles
from the Resident Evil games but being
bombarded with dead eyes every second
like this is a hack and slash game does
not mix with a game that has 10 controls
fixed camera angles and an emphasis on
Resource Management if anything play
this game to hear Bruce Campbell reprise
his role as Ash
oh
my God
welcome to the slightly more realistic
land of the PlayStation 2 where
characters have segmented fingers and
multiple textures and even sometimes
hair that moves Fistful of boomstick is
Ash's first outing into this generation
of consoles and much like Hail to the
King it picks up with Ash trying to
figure out what to do with his life in
the wake of the trilogy of movies this
time instead of having a girlfriend and
going back to the cabin he's drowning
his sorrows at a bar in the town of
Dearborn a city composed entirely of
bars strip clubs and hardware stores
which does sound like Ash's kind of
place some jackass the local TV station
plays a recording of some of the
passages of the book and summons evil to
everyone in town watching the broadcast
like that Creep Show episode with the
exact plot and Ted Raimi thus begins a
semi-open world jaunt into the Evil Dead
Universe the combat here is slightly
more optimized but nothing exciting you
get some basic combos with the chainsaw
and shovel and more ammo types for the
shotgun it has more of a spawn
Armageddon feel to it which is
frustrating at times but still
serviceable enough I'm glad you're in a
new location instead of just rehashing
the woods and cabin from Hail to the
King however the city areas in the
beginning of the game are unforgivingly
confusing to navigate they're designed
like a maze and there's so few decent
landmarks that it's easy to get confused
I wasn't joking when I said there's a
strip club in a hardware store every few
feet here and that's like certainly
pretty novel as a joke but it hurts the
game's playability because now
everything here looks the [ __ ] same I
have no landmarks this game's
progression is laid out as a series of
fetch quests given to you by NPCs like
go find a police badge so you can fool
the cop into letting you pass a security
checkpoint or find a bunch of silver
objects to use for a spell to close
these portals to hell that are opening
up everywhere or gather these four
colored crystals to open a door
and while that doesn't sound bad on
paper in execution they're incredibly
frustrating because this game has no
save stations or item boxes and again
with the infinitely spawning enemies
deadites once again appear repeatedly in
the game's map no matter how many times
you kill them but to make matters worse
this game can process way more NPCs on
screen than a PS1 can so sometimes you
can get jumped by 30 enemies at once and
this game's hack and slashy combat
doesn't really give you the upper hand
at least the chainsaw doesn't run out of
gas this time that shouldn't have taken
more than one try to nail down but
nearly every enemy encounter involves
you getting surrounded and ganged up on
with a move set that isn't really
designed for slashing it like six
enemies at once there's a little bit of
Slash damage but not enough to keep from
getting overwhelmed this boy needs some
Blades of chaos or something plus the
block only protects you from the front
which is useless when most of the
enemies are standing behind you as
you're targeting only one of them at a
time just blow them all away with the
shotgun it's not worth the hassle so
much of this boils down to being told to
go grab an item then running around
aimlessly in these confusingly laid out
areas searching for that item just to
get it and then be told you need the
next thing in a way this one is also
like another Resident Evil clone game
but without any of the subtlety in the
design and it's not brilliant about
keeping you on track to the next key
item in a clever way there isn't any
backtracking to a previous area of new
knowledge or new items you're just in
one massive area that feels like a
[ __ ] Mobius strip just imagine if you
got to the mansion in Resident Evil and
there were like 90 percent less doors
and a bunch of scared NPCs standing
around telling you what to get instead
of just being like sort of obvious
through context clues it doesn't feel
like you're figuring out this game and
unraveling the puzzle it just feels like
you're being led around on a tight leash
and sometimes they choke you with it
harder Daddy and this game doesn't have
a proper checkpoint or save system
either you have to manually save with
limited items and there's no save
station like a typewriter so sometimes
you go long stretches of forgetting the
save and then risk losing major swaths
of progress but because they're also
limited and you don't have a specific
station to remind you to save you have
to be careful not to save too often or
save in a spot where you'll end up just
getting killed repeatedly because an
enemy is secretly right behind you and
you didn't see them before saving the
menu thankfully the feeling of being
totally lost regresses in the latter
half of the game once you get to the
museum it becomes a little more
navigable but not any less tedious and
by this point you're just so exhausted
already that it doesn't help much and
then the solutions to the progression
become even more obtuse like finding two
vases to open the secret hatch behind
the painting that has a magic proximity
detector that leads you to Hidden
compartments that you need to blow open
with a stick of dynamite to reveal a
green Crystal but then you also need to
find a blue yellow and red Crystal and
then place them in the right order and
then also the secret compartment is in
the Civil War exhibit on the surface
level this stuff feels like pretty
standard survival horror obtuse puzzle
solutions but it's made more tedious by
not having a dedicated map to navigate
the layout of this place and also being
bombarded with enemies that drain your
resources quickly and then they just
don't drop health and ammo frequently
enough to compensate the museum wasn't
as hard to explore as the city but it's
where I found myself getting repeatedly
stuck because of the just sheer amount
of respawning enemies in the amount of
running in circles at one point I had to
just save right before the boss
encounter and spend like an hour
wandering around using explosives on
large hordes of enemies to farm some
health and ammo off them
and no I wasn't wasting the explosives
because the only way to beat the boss is
to use your shovel to fling this
projectile back at him something the
game has never told you you can do
before because none of the other
deadites have projectiles in the game by
this point at least the pre-rendered
cutscene looks pretty nice for the time
and Bruce is a solid voice actor so his
performance keeps me engaged because you
know I like Ash and yes I like him
enough to bear with the game's [ __ ]
then this next section is just so
annoying I want to give up [ __ ] this
stupid maze in the woods [ __ ] how dark
it is and the fact that I have to just
boost the brightness on my TV to see
what's going on [ __ ] the confusing
layout that again has no map to speak of
and [ __ ] how stingy this game is with
giving you health items I'm mad again
because of a maze in the woods I'm
seeing a pattern the town is full of
annoying and tedious backtracking
because everything is way too far away
from each other finding hidden items
that are a little too well hidden for a
main quest objective and then I create a
Time Paradox by accidentally walking
forward a little too far and these
monsters have Ash's ancestor held
hostage then I lose like 20 minutes of
progress because I walked two steps in
the wrong direction I forgot to save and
I will definitely give up here I don't
want to play this game anymore this
game's poo poo Diego you take over okay
you go cool off X I know how to handle
this baby so in order to avoid getting
your ancestor killed and Marty mcflying
yourself out of existence you have to
gather all five pieces of a page
containing a spell yes another fetch
Quest a true Soul must Embrace death if
he is to travel beyond the grave
whoa I think this puzzle requires me to
kill myself
okay I might have read a little too deep
into that one what you're supposed to do
is use the Dead Eye possession spell
then walk over to this door and you'll
be granted access admittedly that's a
pretty cool puzzle I think it's awesome
that Ash is able to cast spells as a
baked in game mechanic there's a strong
variation of spells that come in pretty
handy when you're surrounded by enemies
and others that give Ash a temporary
buff like this one that quite literally
makes him buff and adds an extra foot to
his height that spell should be a hit
with the ladies but if I'm being honest
I didn't make much use of them
throughout my playthrough unless it was
absolutely necessary to solve a puzzle I
never bothered to memorize the button
combinations needed to cast them and
going back and forth between gameplay
and the slow menus brings the game's
pacing to a screeching halt I wish that
I could switch between spells through an
inventory wheel I can easily pull up
with all five pieces of the Spell Tome
now collected we head back to Eldridge
he uses the spell to hide tell it out of
there through a Vortex and leaves our
ancestor the blacksmith held hostage by
these bbds big beautiful deadites
luckily we have our new learned spell
that allows us to possess these monsters
and we free the blacksmith I love the
banter between these two williamses time
travel is an element that's sort of been
a Mainstay of the Evil Dead franchise
ever since Evil Dead 2 and I love the
idea of Ash interacting with his
ancestors putting two charismatic
Personalities in the same space makes
for some fun dialogue big props to the
voice actor who plays the blacksmith
they could have easily just gotten Bruce
Campbell to voice his ancestor as well
just with a slightly different accent or
Cadence but this guy
whoever he is I couldn't tell you
because the game's credits don't bother
to show you which character the voice
actors are playing and IMDb wasn't much
help this guy does a good job of
bringing that trademark Williams wit to
his character
so shout out to you
whoever you are
hot on eldridge's trail we end up in
Dearborn Michigan
1863. during the middle of a civil war
Eldritch holds himself up behind an
impenetrable Fort we're gonna need the
help of the feuding unionist and
Confederates to get through it we pick
up a sword adding another weapon to our
impressively expanding Arsenal in order
to get into town we're gonna need to
present some identification and this
smart badge that has been taking up
space in our inventory since the very
beginning of the game finally has some
use it's here that we meet the next
descendant of the Williams family tree
he's a general for the Union Army and he
advises us of a family heirloom the Old
Blacksmith left for us in preparation
for this very moment
Mama now we're cooking with gas this
Gatling gun is hands down my favorite
weapon in this game mowing down hordes
of deadites with this baby feels just
right after closing up a couple of
vortexes and convincing the two armies
to cease fire we stormed the fort and
prepare to confront Eldridge what
follows is what I consider to be the
game's best boss fight after seemingly
being shot dead Eldritch transforms into
a giant two-armed deadite unlike some of
the previous boss fights your means of
doing damage are very obvious here
thanks to these conveniently laid out
explosive barrels I like that the camera
is pulled back far enough to give you a
clear view of the arena and this big
space is a great setting for a boss
fight overall just a tightly designed
boss after defeating the ugly son of a
[ __ ] we end up in a Twisted present
time where deadites have taken over and
enslaved Humanity so we kinda get to see
that alternate ending of Army of
Darkness that the studio thought was too
depressing come on where's your sense of
shot in freuda did I pronounce that
right cool post-apocalyptic Aesthetics
aside this level sucks hard remember
that cool puzzle from before where we
needed to possess a dead eye in order to
open a door they bring that back for
this level but there's an obnoxious
amount of emphasis on it you have to do
it like four times and you have to be a
specific type of Deadeye for each door
you got to make sure that you don't mess
up and deplete your Mana because then
you'll find yourself running around
scrounging for whatever bit of magic
energy enemies drop you know that system
Resident Evil 4 has the one that makes
enemies drop whatever resources you're
in need of so you always feel like you
have just enough to get by and not get
stuck yeah that ain't here so after
dealing with that collecting some runes
needed to open a door and saying the
magic words we confront the Deadeye
Queen responsible for this mess who
could this queen be I hear you ask it's
the one prominent lady character this
game has Trish what a Twist Ash just
can't catch a break with the ladies this
final boss fight is really underwhelming
all you gotta do is Dodge these barf
balls until you see an opening and Chuck
a dynamite stick out her mouth Child's
Play but I do like this animation of the
Deadeye Queen ballooning up when she
swallows the dynamite it is very Looney
Tunes like but defeating the big final
monster just isn't enough in true Evil
Dead fashion Ash finds himself in
another hairy situation in an attempt to
open a portal back home he winds up in
fetal Japan where he's been recounting
his story to Japanese emperor kamayama
who's wielding the kandarian summoning
stones and intends to use their power
against Khan the evil force crashes the
party and Ash takes the opportunity to
grab a katana kill the now possessed
Samurai and imperfect Japanese
or tutorial
groovy
not bad for a complete [ __ ] Evil Dead
Fistful of boomstick is in this awkward
spot where it's trying to be both an
action game and puzzle exploration game
sadly it doesn't excel in either
Department the combat system is decent
and there are a healthy amount of
weapons to choose from but getting
through large groups of enemies feels
more like a chore because Ash's attacks
don't feel like they were designed to
handle these many enemies at once while
there are a few clever puzzles they were
held back by the aimless wandering I
found myself doing so often
this game desperately needs a map
especially in a game where environments
are indistinguishable from one another
we need an evil dead game that sticks to
nailing one major component the first
try to be Resident Evil and this one is
somewhere between Resident Evil and
Devil May Cry I think we're getting
closer
[Music]
that's my sister you sick [ __ ]
hey
listen
I know why Kenneth King wasn't in church
today
why
because the daughter disappeared
Jessica
what do you mean she disappeared
well
Kenneth woke up this morning
Jessica wasn't there
bed wasn't even slept in
he's thinking she ran off I know her and
Wayne were supposed to be getting
married what back in June
maybe she got cold feet
oh hey
we're here
[Music]
huh
[Music]
foreign
guys what the hell happened here no I
gotta pee is there a bathroom anywhere
you guys gotta get us out of here
there's something in those trees that
ain't no man we're done with that stop
that sorry but there's evil in this
place and the Delta won't start
I don't think that's a sign of evil our
Delta wouldn't start either I guess
that's what we get for driving 45 year
old cars what have you guys been up to
all night playing games and shooting at
scary noises
I think we'll be okay if we stop playing
these hey this one that's Ted Rainey in
it no oh my God I already like this one
so much more they stopped trying to make
it a Resident Evil game and decide to
just make a Devil May Cry game instead
that's what we've been waiting for it's
what we want it all along this one
immediately discounts continuity with
the other games and just picks up right
after the movies with Ash in a mental
Asylum after not being able to properly
explain to the authorities why his
friends were cut into a million pieces
with a chainsaw grafted to his
self-mutilated body the TV series would
also kind of gloss over how he got out
of that one Ash's belongings including
the Necronomicon end up in the hands of
the asylum's evil Warden and he begins
experimenting with it to create all
kinds of nasty interdimensional Terrors
it's kind of like the suffering if
you're old enough to remember that game
right away I have to praise this game's
graphics and cut scenes this looks
really clean for a PS2 game and I love
the look of these models and
environments plus the cutscenes have
some really fun stylish and energetic
direction that captures that rainy-esque
feel Bruce's performance here is the
strongest of the three games and the
story is just so much fun this is like
my dream Evil Dead game where has this
one been all my life listen up shake and
bake I eat evil for breakfast and danger
for dinner so spread the word
Ash is back in business
to top it all off you get Sam a half
deadite wisecracking sidekick that's
unkillable you can punt him into a wood
chipper and watch his unwilling
regeneration over and over but Sam is
useful for helping Ash find the
locations of the breaches between the
world of the living and the dead and
sealing them up he's voiced by the
legendary Ted raymie who you may know
from like the five or so characters he
played in the series or Hoffman from
Spider-Man or that guy in Candyman or
maybe you know him from the Quarry
because that game is really popular
right now and he's pretty good in it
either way I'm stoked to have him here
he livens things up by giving Ash a
sidekick that's also jokey and sarcastic
to match wits with but like isn't going
to die at the 30 minute Mark of the
movie due to their actor wanting to quit
the little guy's inclusion really makes
regeneration stand out from any other
game movie or comic book in the
franchise his over-the-top personality
forces ass to be the straight man for a
change due to the game's uh video gaming
nature the slapstick comedy is at an
all-time high the duo well mostly Sam is
constantly put through the ringer the
physical humor is the highlight of the
game's story otherwise you have what is
a straightforward Evil Dead Plot
Professor Nobi makes a surprising but
welcome return and acts as a ghostly
tour guide as our heroes embark on a
journey where they must close off
portals that are trying to invade the
peaceful Town been there done that but
it won't be so straightforward the
portals are guarded by big gross
monstrous faces known as Soul leaders
and the only way to get past them is by
completing escort missions where Sam
absorbs a deadite spirit and must carry
it over to the Soul Eater to
incapacitate it this is the common
through line in all the levels of EDR
you'll slash and blast your way through
hordes of deadites as they try to stop
Sam from carrying out his task this can
be frustrating at times because if Sam
Bites the Dust it won't be game over but
you'll have to make your way all the way
back to the spirit's spawn point and you
know nobody likes tedium thankfully the
combat here is the most enjoyable of
these old and Evil Dead games you'll
make slight and heavy attacks juggle
enemies and there's plenty of boomstick
to go around for everyone on a kind of
unlimited ammo
of course no DMC clone is complete
without some sort of Rage mode Ash is
able to tap into his bad side to deal
extra damage without completely losing
control on the other side of the Soul
Eaters resides one of the portals but
they're guarded by a boss character
these are pretty easy to kill but they
each have a cool and unique design one
of my favorite features of these games
has been all the different attachments
you can find for Ash's arm the Highlight
here is the Harpoon Gun I'll let it
speak for itself
thank you
yeah
while all this is going on things take a
turn for the worst and Sally Ash's
lawyer gets kidnapped by the dark ones
for Professor Reinhardt and will now be
acting as a sacrifice in turn for
Godlike Powers this puts a press on
matters while Sam is reciting an
incantation to close one of the portals
he flubs it and this causes the portal
to suck the two into a hellish Dimension
I guess he learned from the best after
battling our way through this heavy
metal infused realm we confront Dr Nut
Job who's Gone full tonight and
officially broke the meter on the ugly
scale Pro tip make sure your health is
topped off before starting this boss
fight there are no Health jobs here and
if you're not well prepared you can end
up getting stuck and will have to resort
to loading an older save with the final
portal closed off and Sally back in safe
hands it's time to pack up and oh wait a
minute this is an evil dead game of
course we have to end on a downer
ha ha
ha
you
I do wonder where the other end of that
portal led to having Ash as the star of
a character action game is a no-brainer
given his Arsenal the chainsaw hand and
Boomstick combo was instantly iconic but
flailing the chainsaw around in live
action always came off as a bit awkward
and impractical
they're just too damn heavy so uh but
this is where video games come in and
turn things up to 11. you feel like a
true badass and Evil Dead regeneration
with all the different attacks you can
pull off with your chainsaw and all of
Ash's other attachments I was not
expecting to like Sam as much as I did
these two have a fun Dynamic even though
it makes Ash come off as very one note
not that he's ever been the deepest
character but in this game he's just the
annoyed cranky guy throughout the
majority of the game and just rips on
Sam along their Journey he does start to
come around at the very last moments of
the story though and I would love to see
more of these two in a comic book or
something like that fun combat Woody
banter and most of all Ted and Bruce as
a dynamic duo makes regeneration a must
play for Evil Dead fans
hey so like you notice how all of the
games so far have had a featuring the
voice of Bruce Campbell on the box
that's important because his inclusion
really legitimizes any Evil Dead project
even if he's only there for like a tiny
bit you know
Ash isn't Ash without Bruce so anyway
this game made the horrible mistake of
including Ash and he sounds like this no
it's a cookbook of course it's the
Necronomicon now let's play
telltale's poker night is a poker game
if you're into that but they have
licensed characters stand in for the
players and unique banter between them
during matches if you ever wanted to
hear Brock from The Venture Brothers
crack some jokes at claptrap from
Borderlands or GLaDOS from Portal well
all of them have their actual voice
actors so I don't know why they cheaped
out here crazy like a few dads of
burning hydrocarbons behind the audio
sensors oh yeah plus Ash just kind of
looks weird in this art style like I
know you can do
a kind of cartoony cell shaded Ash and
it would look pretty good because he's
just got such exaggerated like cartoony
features but
why does this look wrong kind of nuts
that this and until dawn were so close
and yet so far on that title okay so
Bruce is voicing Ash here already got
the points for that his design is based
on the TV show making this the first
video game incarnation of the El Jefe
version of the character along with some
fun Easter eggs from the series like his
hand puppet and the new metal hand made
for him by Pablo Ash's quips are pretty
good when you get to hear them
but we run into a problem with this game
Ash is helpless and spends 90 percent of
his time in this game just moaning in
agony and pain after being injured by
big scary monsters that he can't battle
I'm not super in love with this game
don't get me wrong I absolutely
understand why Dead Bite Dawn is as
popular as it is and why so many people
find it so appealing it's a stark
contrast with other horror games where
you're not necessarily on even footing
with the monsters and demons but you at
least have the means to overpower them
and survive the helplessness is unique
in this game the developers wanted you
to take a stealthy route or play more
defensively instead of offensively I
understand all of this dead by daylight
is also a really cool celebration of the
slasher horror genre by including so
many horror icons and giving them unique
gameplay features true to their Roots
but for me personally this game feels
like trying to use a computer from 1999.
you go over and click on something and
then you just watch a progress bar fill
up and it's just loading and loading and
loading and then after that you finally
get to the next thing and then you click
on it and then it's just loading
and loading and loading but you can't
fall asleep during this process so the
computer sometimes asks if you're still
there if you don't click yes in time a
short electric shock comes out of your
mouse and tases you until your fingers
are numb and occasionally a guy will
walk up and then jerk you away from the
computer and put your ass on a meat hook
like Leatherface sometimes it actually
is Leatherface and while the guest
characters as killers are all awesome
the survivors pose a huge problem for me
having characters like Lori Strode Leon
Kennedy and yes Ash Williams in this
game and then treating them like
helpless babies incapable of raising a
fist in self-defense drives me [ __ ]
crazy a pretty huge chunk of these
survivors are not characters that would
stealth around and try to find their way
out Ash even at his weakest in Evil Dead
1 wasn't this much of a pansy he was
smashing Linda's head with a wooden log
being so defenseless as some of these
characters causes a lot of frustration
for me and I'd rather just play another
horror game where I can see the same
characters in their element being able
to like punch the forces of evil
squaring the chops instead of crying and
pissing their pants if you wanted this
to be true to the character it should
have been Ash as a killer wandering
around the woods with a chainsaw hand
and the matches with him in them would
put a special voice filter and texture
change on the Survivor character models
to make them into deadites running in
Terror as he's trying to hack them down
or slam them onto hooks
you know like that other game
that's enough evil for one night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get the hot glue gun
and a montage
[Music]
what the hell is this thing how am I
supposed to do anything with this
it's practical
practical for what
show me again
Charlie
[Music]
boy
seems pretty practical for that
[Music]
you guys even put gas in this thing
dude did you know there was an evil dead
mobile game
no
thank you
there are some games that not even the
powerful dark magic of the Necronomicon
or kandarian dagger can pull from the
ghastly depths of the delisted mobile
games graveyard
well maybe emulation but we don't resort
to such unethical practices here we just
steal the footage from someone else's
channel so let's pay our respects to the
fallen and go over the long gone Evil
Dead mobile games
first up is Army of Darkness defense
this game encapsulates the climax of the
third movie in the franchise and adapts
it into a tower defense game that's
pretty much what Ash and the townsfork
were doing in the third Act of aod so
yeah this adds up the mechanics here are
very simple Ash automatically shoots at
any deadites coming his way all you have
to worry about is navigating him
activating special attacks like this
extra powerful Boomstick blast and
summoning peasants and knights to Aid
you in battle as long as you have the
resources in between waves you can spend
your hard-earned gold on more troops
upgrades for ash himself or a health
increase for the castle you're defending
hearing sound bites from the movie is
amusing when contrasted against the
cartoony art style Ash looks like he
belongs in the Marvel Superhero Squad
here
I want Evil Dead the game we have Evil
Dead the game at home sweetie in all
seriousness this cute chibi style
retelling of the first movie looks
really Charming the gang's all here
Cheryl Linda and Scotty will accompany
you as you platform shoot and chop your
way through the dreaded Woods in this
top-down action adventure game it was
the woods himself house
they're alive and they're actually the
treats I don't want to picture what that
scene would look like in this seemingly
kid-friendly mobile game endless Runners
were once a big thing in the mobile game
space and Evil Dead took a piece of the
pie while it was hot Evil Dead endless
nightmare is based on the 2013 reboot
you play as the handsome guy from that
movie
hey hey the kids being a think of the
kids what separates this endless runner
from most is that you're free to run in
any direction you want you'll be sworn
with hordes of deadites your goal is to
complete side tasks collect drops of
blood you can spend on weapons and
upgrades and to last as long as you can
10 seconds I lasted longer when I [ __ ]
up the kids Mia I like that the weapons
you can buy from the shop are
conventional tools like a nail gun and a
simple box cutter it Embraces the
traditional household and makeshift
weapons the Evil Dead franchise is known
for
I was not expecting to be talking about
Family Guy of all things in an evil dead
retrospective But Here We Are Family Guy
The Quest for Stuff is a mobile game
that appears to be solely designed to
pass the time while you're in the John
Quahog has been brought to ruins after
another one of Peter's extensive brawls
against the giant chicken now it's up to
you to rebuild the town in Your Vision
you'll complete all sorts of tasks in
exchange for coins that you can spend on
resources for your version of Quahog
like many free-to-play games there's a
shop that features premium items that
can be purchased through micro
transactions one of them being Ash
Williams who was added during the
seasonal event The Haunting way back in
October of 2016. he comes equipped with
night lights that can be used to
paralyze Boogeyman that spawn during
this event you can always count on ash
to come well equipped to fight monsters
but uh you know this isn't better than
the time Ash dropped and tilted towers
with the predator and Spider-Man
when is Ash Williams coming to fortnite
nah he doesn't need fortnite yeah this
one counts too we covered the Family Guy
mobile game we're leaving no stone
unturned it's a skin you can buy in the
game's item shop but I did want to give
them props for a really cool Recreation
of the cabin that's currently on the
island out in the woods instantly dating
this video when you get there random
zombie enemies spawn and attack you and
Ash is there in the cabin to give you
some unique bits of dialogue depending
on what skin you're wearing plus you can
buy a shotgun from him for some gold
bars they didn't have to go as detailed
as they did with this cabin location but
I think it's really cool that they did
and Ash's special emote in this exact
spot is a pretty cool sight to see
unlike most evil dead games you can
actually go down into the fruit Cellar
here you can go loot a chest and explore
around it's a neat little addition to
the current season of fortnite you
should check it out before it's gone oh
and if you get the ash skin be sure to
use my Creator code Xavier GM it helps
me out a lot as I really appreciate it
thank you unless you're watching this
video a year from now in which case you
missed the boat on going to the cabin
but you know that's how I feel about the
Deadpool Battle pass skin in this game
it's kind of refreshing to have a game
with so little permanence built into it
it teaches you that not everything lasts
forever some experiences are meant to be
finite blinks of time
never to be repeated except hitting the
gritty that's eternal
[Music]
foreign
about a chosen one maybe he knows how to
defeat the evil uh this guy uh Campbell
that has to be him right
man this handwriting sucks clatu varada
nisto or is that a c
foreign
County junior
brother
wrong on both accounts though you do
have a pretty strong jawline
uh I don't know this guy looks too young
to be Campbell are you sure it's the
right guy I did I it's a Campbell
that's what it says in all the legal
documents a Campbell but Xavier Diego
looks like you guys are in a bit of a
jam huh does your dad ever teach you
anything about slaying demons
hmm
can't say it ever really came up during
dad talk
but I have been playing a ton of the new
Evil Dead game and boys let me tell you
it'll teach you a thing or two about
cutting down the undead and whooping on
some dead eyes you know what I'm saying
check it out
all right Gentlemen Just make sure to
close the book gently on your way out
will ya
what did I just say saber games did the
impossible the Mad sons of [ __ ]
actually managed to get every Evil Dead
installment Under One Roof for the first
time ever
when I played this game earlier in the
year before the release I met some of
the developers behind the scenes and
they told me what a daunting task this
was to pull together
let me just break down how much of an
accomplishment this is if you're not in
the know
the reason continuity is so loose in
this franchise is because every single
Evil Dead thing has been produced by a
different studio and as such is
technically owned by a different group
of people Evil Dead 2 was supposed to
start with a recap of footage from the
first movie with the final shot of the
previous film leading right into this
one but Sam raymi and Company couldn't
get the license to use the footage from
Evil Dead 1 their own movie and had to
reshoot all of that and simplify it to
the most important elements which is why
Linda is the only one at the cabin with
him this time she's the only one that
appears in the plot of Evil Dead 2.
ideally these two movies would flow into
each other perfectly if not for the
weird rights [ __ ] and because Army
of Darkness was at a third Studio they
had to do the same thing all over again
then the TV show which was at a fourth
company could only use footage and
Concepts from the first two movies which
is why they played it pretty Coy about
ever mentioning events from Army of
Darkness until much later in the show
that's not even mentioning the Remake
that means in order to have this image
before you of all four versions of ash
side by side this game developer had to
make calls to like a dozen different
people and all these different companies
and go through all the red tape and
legal Shenanigans to get the license to
use
all of this
it may seem paltry at first glance that
it's just four different ashes next to
each other but this is the result of
some serious fan dedication on the part
of the developers and the fact that they
went so far is to get the Remake
characters too when they didn't even
need to it's just so [ __ ] cool it's
all here if there's anything I can say
about this game above all else it's that
the people who made it are clearly
really huge fans of the franchise and
did their research there are a ton of
little nods and references in the
gameplay and the multiplayer maps to
deep cuts from the series they got as
many returning cast members and
likenesses as they could for the
playable characters and playing this
game just feels like watching an evil
dead movie all the gratuitous blood
badass kills and snappy one-liners you
could want all the characters are fully
voiced too you can just have a squad of
all ashes fighting an evil Ash as the
demon player Ash is all around I also
played this game with Bruce Campbell one
time so there's even more Ash in that
round Ash plosion here's a whole video
about how that went you can check it out
after this one if you're curious Bruce
was clearly tired of watching stupid
YouTubers play this game by that point
because he was doing it for like six
hours that day but he was still super
cool to all of us and it was a great
time any honored my request from many
years ago be more mean to me
despite all that I'll still be as Fair
as I can to this game and not let my
fanboyism color this review that being
said I do really like this game despite
being fed up with the genre it's in okay
so my big problem with a lot of the
asymmetrical horror multiplayer genre is
that playing as the human Survivor is
typically so punishing and so unfair
that it's almost pointless to play it
these games tend to have such a horrible
disadvantage for the human team that it
can be hard to find it fun at times when
you're just getting repeatedly beaten
into the ground by the overpowered
monsters and Killers this game may be
the first of its genre to explore the
concept
what if the survivors didn't suck ass at
everything ever and as such you can pick
up guns and use weapons things that Ash
Williams does Evil Dead 2022's major
standout factor for me is that it just
has satisfying melee combat the feedback
on these weapons is great I actually
feel like a physical threat to the
deadites and not like I'm just breaking
my fists over a brick wall like I can
actually kick some ass in this game
getting overwhelmed by 10 enemies at
once you can beat them all without
taking any damage if you're quick enough
on the controls this is the best Evil
Dead combat so far the chainsaw and kill
animations are so fun and having the
ability to aim and shoot in a third
person over the shoulder angle it's a
real game changer I know all this [ __ ]
is standard in games now but after
coming off of several PS2 games this is
a massive leap I have been drowning
trying to get my fix of good dead at
killing mechanics you have a team of
four playing as various protagonists
from across the entire franchise running
around a massive map to find the
kendarian dagger to destroy the
Necronomicon and defeat the dark ones
who wrote it those characters being here
is pretty cool because they've only ever
been briefly mentioned in previous
entries in the series on the other side
one player can choose a specific Deadeye
character from the series to spawn as
and torture the human players the demon
can lay traps spawn enemies possess
deadites possess Vehicles possess
players and even appear as a boss
character like Henrietta evil Ash or
elegas from the TV show this game is a
ton of fun to play with friends and
thankfully a lot of my friends are also
Die Hard Evil Dead fans that all being
said
I would have vastly preferred a single
player story based game I know I know
I'm a broken record in the fruit seller
I said the same thing about playing as
the predator in hunting grounds the
gameplay is solid I just want a more
linear and focused experience with that
same gameplay as a base but unlike
predator hunting grounds this game
partially delivers on that with a whole
bunch of solo missions with unique
objectives these don't really have cut
scenes or unique dialogue in most cases
but it's something to help scratch that
itch a little bit like a story mission
where you're essentially reenacting
scenes from Evil Dead 2 just in gameplay
form and fighting off deadites in the
woods while Linda's severed head taunts
you this stuff wasn't 100 necessary to
add but I do appreciate the hell out of
it because it keeps me content enough in
my single player survival horror
Cravings however the single player
missions are pretty brutally difficult
when you don't have any backup well
maybe difficult isn't the right word I
would say tedious because some of them
are so long and don't have checkpoints
this Pablo Mission requires you running
all over the map for like 20 minutes
doing all these different fetch quests
getting bombarded with enemies on one
health bar if there was just a
checkpoint halfway through would be so
much easier but everyone I know who
plays this game has told me that they
really just did not like doing this
Mission I just feel like they could be a
little bit less punishingly long in some
cases
and it kind of sucks because like you
have to play them to unlock all the
characters so
strap in and get used to it while there
aren't a lot of them these multiplayer
maps are a lot of fun to explore I
really love just how massive these
locations are and how easy it would be
to get lost in them if not for the map
and objectives keeping you on track I
don't want to get lost on accident but
if I get lost on purpose because the
level is fun to look around then that's
a different story this also has to be
the greatest Recreation of the cabin in
a game so far it's accurate down to
every last nail in the walls and
ironically you don't even need to spend
that much time here in most matches
exploring these beautifully crafted
levels is a delight but wander off too
far and you'll be sure to have your soul
swallowed teamwork is key in this game
sticking together as you collect pages
of the Necronomicon is the only way to
stand the chance against the demon
player spend too much time alone in the
woods and your fear meter will increase
leaving you open to possessions there
are ways to slow down the rate at which
your fear increases obviously spending
quality time with your fellow survivors
but also lighting up campfires and using
your flashlight in dark areas keep in
mind that both are limited you'll need
to have matchsticks in your inventory to
light the campfires and your flashlight
can run out of juice this along with the
need to keep an eye on your ammo count
and health items put an emphasis on
Survival horror elements in a game I was
expecting to be predominantly action
oriented which don't get me wrong
there's plenty of that but if you don't
take the time to make pit stops at
cabins shops and houses to scrounge for
supplies you'll be at a severe
disadvantage especially late in the game
when the demon player has only gotten
stronger having a well-balanced team is
also a big factor in ensuring your
Survival characters are divided into
classes you have your damage dealing
Warriors like Henry the red leaders that
give your teammates Buffs long range
Specialists known as hunters and support
characters that are in charge of keeping
your teammates healed and can help with
managing everyone's fear levels each
character has a skill tree for you to
dig into and pick out which perks best
fit your play style I find that having
Cheryl and your team is a huge leg up
her healing AOE is a literal Lifesaver
during these late game phases when
things get really dicey this game's not
without its flaws though and the
developers who worked on it and are
watching this video just know that this
is tough love I'm only telling you this
for your own good because I love you and
I know you can do better
[Music]
the vehicles [ __ ] suck in this game
the driving is so jerky and hard to
control and the car breaks apart and
craps out at the drop of a hat
it's like passing over a gravel road is
liable to make your engine disintegrate
God help you if you accidentally bump a
fence post in this thing or AAA is not
picking your stupid cyborg ass up one of
these solo missions revolves entirely
around you driving around the car and it
breaks every five seconds this game's
also kind of buggy sometimes like this
one time I got a bug where I wasn't able
to like fight
like my triggers just stopped working I
wasn't able to punch or kick or do
anything
and so I became a liability to the team
and that was pretty horrible
I think in my mind this can be the last
asymmetrical multiplayer game based on
an 80s horror franchise Friday the 13th
was a first try dead by daylight got
really popular predator hunting grounds
is pretty cool and this one is like
everything I would want from that
premise for a game
I do really like this one after this I
want to go back to making more of
whatever the hell alien isolation was
because that was great but on the
horizon we still have the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre game which seems a little
redundant given Leatherface is already
in dead by daylight I think there's a
Ghostbusters game doing this [ __ ] now
and of course everyone's favorite killer
clowns from outer space good [ __ ]
luck with that one I'm sure all the
killer clowns Ultra fans who are in
their 50s will definitely keep that game
servers up and alive for the foreseeable
future I think Evil Dead stands Out
Among the rest that feel either not
really that fun for me or just seem like
they're trying to cash in on a trend by
grabbing some random IP that can fit the
mold of this style of game in a really
saturated and at times frustrating
sub-genre of gaming Evil Dead is the one
that I can get the most enjoyment out of
and this game is absolutely a love
letter to the fans
I hope this one stays around for a long
time with new content and updates coming
out because there's actually a lot of
material for them to keep pulling from
you could add like Ruby and ball you
could put Ted Ramey in the game I think
they were saying they're gonna do that
they could put more maps based on the TV
show you could put that Bob Ross guy
from The Creep Show episode in that
would be pretty funny I don't know who
you'd have to talk to about getting the
rights for that character oh yeah
there's evil dead Rises coming out soon
you could [ __ ] throw some [ __ ] in
there from that
[Music]
yeah not a chance don't worry I'll do it
uh Xavier I think you probably got about
the only chance don't [ __ ] it up don't
[ __ ] it up
don't [ __ ] it up
[ __ ] it up don't [ __ ] it up
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I uh
I think
I think we defeated the evil
thanks for watching y'all make sure to
sub to Xavier and Diego for more fun
content like this I'm Andy Campbell you
find me at Andy cable GG on Twitch
YouTube and all other social media
have a groovy day hey thank you for
watching I just wanted to give a big
shout out and thank you to everyone who
helped put this video together it's been
a labor of love we've been working on it
for close to a year and I'm so glad it's
finally out a big thank you to Andy
Campbell for appearing in this video it
really meant a lot to us uh we're all
big fans he's a super cool guy thank you
so much to Diego for of course
co-writing the reviews with me and then
also helping to edit those James and
Maddie from Watchtower database are the
best ever thanks so much to both of them
for appearing in the video and also to
James for helping with the VFX stuff
that meant the world to us
Molly did amazing on the storyboards I'm
gonna put those up on patreon at some
point soon Jacob was of course super
heavily involved in the props and
costumes and editing and color
correction and all sorts of different
parts of the production he was super
helpful the whole way through thank you
so much to my dad for uh putting up with
us filming in your basement and helping
to direct all the live action stuff and
of course our Pals over at the good boys
Gwen and Khalil you guys are awesome Ben
really came through helping us get a few
extra shots of the Gmod background for
the final bit of the video he's the best
and of course thanks to warplanet online
for helping us keep the lights on and
sponsoring this video see you next time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]